need motivation watch a top 10 with
beliebe nation hey it's Evan Carmichael
and this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know that there's something greater
inside you as well you have Michael
Jordan level talent at something so get
ready to chase happiness be dangerous
and stop talking with Gary Vaynerchuk
and my take on his top ten hopes a
success vol 22 to give you the belief
that you need
ok let's kick it off with real number 1
chase happiness how many people by show
of hands work in a job and are desperate
for their side hustle to become their
career just raise your hands
so many of you created golden handcuffs
for yourself that aren't a letting you
leave your job because you need to make
a hundred thirty thousand a year now
because you wanted seven hundred more
square feet in your apartment
where you wanted a BMW instead of a
Toyota
something I've realized that really kind
of caught me off guard is how many
people spend more money on than they can
afford the fact that 35% of this
audience wants their side hustle to be
their careers but the reason they can't
is because they can't quit their job
because they need their job to pay for
dumb to impress people they hate and so
you're not happy because you wanted two
or three things that mean absolutely
nothing why you're not willing to take
one step backwards for a step for the
rest of your life go do your thing
you're gonna die it's going to end
something bad is gonna happen something
great is gonna happen for most of all
nothing's gonna happen unless you do
something please stop looking for
Commission please go do that thing you
wanted to do ask that person out start
that company quit that [ __ ] job you
can always get another [ __ ] job rule
number two play the long game most
people start businesses to take the
money out to buy themselves things which
is why they never build one
you understand there's a fundamental
reason I have the premiere that I have
only thing I have is energy for the long
term when you can oversell your reality
build to the new reality that's how you
pick four [ __ ] media I was able to
over the last five years grow us from 22
people to 800 people from 3 million to a
hundred million in revenue because I can
continue to do my model we're gonna make
less money this year at a hundred
million than we made last year at 67 net
I don't mean percentage net historically
I've liked to run them where one year is
profitable in the next year's not so the
growth is there but the non profitable
other every other year was predicated on
me being able to invest in people
advertising or resources more people
more capabilities because I'm gonna take
the whole pie
99% the marquetry and the 1% that isn't
and has the talent wins every time
which makes no sense because unless
you're gonna die you should only play
long-term
if you're gonna live to be in 2020 you
might as well play to be in 2020 rule
number three be dangerous in everything
never ever be at the mercy of something
else
so why I'm the best at my craft I don't
want to be at mercy of my own employees
it's why I got my hands in absolutely
everything
what if they quit what if they get sick
well if they get bored
what if they win the lottery that's
literally how I think about everything
that's why I mean everything I don't
think we're managed but I'm dangerous
enough in everything cuz I don't want a
point of failure your point of failure
is called Google they literally change
it no matter how evergreen and white hat
you've been they just might decide that
video content is part of their macro
strategy so what what I always think is
when you got something working always
have a nest egg of 20% of your money and
energy of building up other things that
if god forbid your ad goes to zero
you're on the course of being okay rule
number four stop talking start doing
people always say that induce the
biggest epidemic in the world is people
talking not doing and especially now and
people always do that but now what
social media does is expose people it
doesn't change people all the hate in
the system that's exposing Twitter to
make you evil you're evil
you know and same with talking and not
doing Twitter and Instagram didn't make
you waste time and not do don't like
delete your app off your phone and think
you're being productive now that's the
byproduct of what's going on here you're
just gonna watch TV instead you're just
gonna play for tonight instead you're
just gonna go to coffee shops and make
pretend you're working and
and people always talk also if you want
to have more confidence checking my 254
series it's free the link to join is in
the description below
we are sluggish we're really strong
we're just being sold that we're not
because there's a lot of money the
reason people aren't patient is they
value other people's opinions too much
in a success world please understand
that success is happiness not net
dollars in rule number five plays smart
today with all the things that have
happened to me I get emails on Facebook
from friends I went to high school with
often starting with Gary you're so lucky
I reply to every single one of them all
of them with the reply of an opening
line first Jan great to see you again
you look great kids super cute PS I am
super not lucky let me remind you Rick
remember when we graduated college and
you went to the Jersey Shore every
weekend and hooked up with chicks and
drank beer I worked you know it when I
was 22 to 28 I was making thirty five to
fifty five thousand dollars a year but I
had no expenses I didn't go on vacations
I didn't buy fancy things so I saved my
money I saved my money I saved my money
and then when the tell you know I had
hundreds of thousands of dollars I
didn't have millions
I had hundreds of thousands of dollars
because I didn't spend anything and and
then I started making a hundred thousand
dollars a year in a hundred fifty
thousand a year and by the time I was
thirty-three thirty-four when I had that
opportunity I still not bought a home I
was still in an apartment I was 33 years
old and I was renting
and because I was saving cash to go on
the offense and I knew something would
happen one day and hid and so when I had
a chance to invest in those companies I
put hundreds of thousands of dollars not
millions but those hundreds made
millions made tens of millions and so
that's it nothing crazy nothing I didn't
have any crazy crazy advantage there's a
lot of people that make fifty five
thousand dollars a year when they're 23
the problem is they go to Coachella and
they want to buy a watch and they want
to buy a BMW and I didn't so I ate for
thirteen years and then I had a moment
and I struck rule number six be a great
leader I stood up on this company in
September and rolled out a new vision
called the Boehner volume model 98% of
them thought I was out of my mind didn't
believe in it at all thought that I'm
like the crazy founder and like I'm
silly but like when it becomes real this
you know lead anytime you have full
buy-in from your employees you're in a
dangerous place it means there should be
some sort of friction from somebody
who's leading up in front and sees
everything and is driving a company
versus people that work in it who are in
the like they're different like my job
is to be like ocean there's an iceberg
I'm gonna move this way and everybody
who's downstairs is like what do you
mean the water's been super clear the
whole time I'm like no no there's an
iceberg but they're in the basement but
like it's been such a nice ride like
this has been so smooth leaders need to
understand what's happening next
employees are executing on the current
and overvalued the past rule number
seven keep at it
being best always plays out at the end
it just takes longer
sure Sam better yeah I mean I think
right now in this world where everyone's
like a section of Russia right
it's just you know in a rush for success
like it if you've really got those
advantages and it's something that
you've always been into before it was
cool you just play it out you just run
that marathon rule number eight stay the
course building that brand no I'm gonna
have a second location at the opening
we're building my friend that's way a
book where that disciplines the same
thing you're doing now just stay the
course stay the course I was literally
the video post yesterday on Instagram
I've been saying for the last six months
a lot randomly like this I don't
understand how people understand that
the thing that you did to get you there
is the thing that gets you to the next
level but people think once you get to a
level now you've got to change it yeah I
think that's when you got to double down
on it people change once they get some
level of success like notice my
reactions I'm like whoa you got to spend
more second location same it's very
funny how humans work like they find
something that works this is like in
health and fitness this is in business
and for some reason there's this need to
find something else when you've just
shown yourself what works so yeah yeah
it's like am I missing there's this
insecurity am i missing something that
could be better when something's clearly
working you know I feel I always used I
always think about I don't know why this
is the analogy I always bring it up it's
like a fruit from a tree it's like
here's a beautiful huge orange tree in
the back of your yard you're pulling the
orange and you're only squeezing like
thirty percent of the juice out
delicious orange juice and you're like
should I grow an apple tree like no like
squeeze more oranges rule number nine
get practical I say you have under right
you'd own the line under it yeah it's
under a hundred you know this is like my
whole mantra of like garage saling and
everything like for example if this
conversation was happening in October I
would be like please buy two giannis
rookies in their 170 bucks they're gonna
go up there for 50 now so you take that
now you got a thousand now you're
sitting here today and I'm like okay
thousand
what would be like my number one thing
to do in 2000 um bring the second a
thousand Luka Don I'd pop find Lucas for
50 apiece buy 20 of them and sell them
for 75 apiece in October when the season
starts just it's just guaranteed you
might want to take a risk on darn old
Baker's a hundred bucks space rookie
Donald's 14 and like that just doesn't
make any sense to me
and so if Donald beats Baker on Monday
Night Football in week 2 I just think
like the math can get the ad real fast
and then if you have more money the real
thing to do is buy these basketball
cards that are about to come out and try
to pull it's gambling you pull up $5,000
Xion rookie card
because it's alt 101 one of 50 patches
autos they call it it's it's really
happening though like all these sneaker
kids are getting into it my generation
is having has children now of the age
that can collect that's what happened to
me and a lot of other people and rule
number ten the last one before a very
special bonus clip is give 40 of the
free the market will speak it's like a
band it's like a nobody was bringing
value bring it back bringing value now I
have a special bonus skip from Gary on
having self-awareness that I think
you're gonna enjoy but before that it's
time for the three-point landing
questions let's go from just watching
the video to taking action here we go
question number one how are you going to
give value to three different people
this week number two what does being a
great leader look like for you and
number three where do you need to stop
talking and start doing now if you like
this video and you're going to take some
action after watching it give me a hash
tag believe down the comments below lack
of self-awareness people who wish they
could be doing something instead of
focusing on what they can do right I
wish I could be like ninja and play for
night I wish I could be like LeBron I
wish I could be like little lose Ebert I
wish I could be like Gary Vee right I
never wished I could be like anybody I
just focused on who I was and I became
Gary Vee I'm not trying to be somebody
else self-awareness is the unlock to
actually doing closing your ears or not
hearing doubt speeds up the process of
execution
because you're not in a place where
you're slowing down and valuing other
people's opinions patience allows you to
run in perpetuity and not over judge
yourself because it hasn't happened in
the first six months that's the formula
Evan thank you so much for having a
couple of seconds and being able to tell
the believed nation a little bit about
empathy whines it means a lot to me that
you would take this valuable real estate
and and time on your channel to give me
some love means a lot it's just good
karma points and so you're just you're
awesome thank you believe nation if
you're into wine at all go to empathy
wines calm my whole careers work was
poured into producing a wine that
rivaled 40 to $60 wine for 20 bucks a
bottle I'm just super excited about this
subscription-based wine business
you can order three six or twelve
bottles in subscription form Rose a
white red
if you cook if you search on Instagram
or Twitter you will be blown away people
are literally like I don't even like
Gary Vee but the wines good super proud
of the effort thanks Evan for the time
wishing you guys all happy and healthy
and if you want more garyvee check out
the top 50 rules video I made on him the
link is right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there I don't think there's
anything wrong with chasing money I just
think that it's usually the quickest way
not to get it work ethic is controllable